let's go next to our caller from the
nine one eight area code caller from
nine one eight go ahead
hi my question is Lennon or McCartney
Lennon or McCartney oh man uh you know I
I think I'm a Lennon guy myself I mean I
think that that Yoko Ono is completely
whacked out of her mind but you know she
also has suffered a lot of trauma in her
life and just because she's bonkers
doesn't necessarily mean that my opinion
of John Lennon needs to be influenced at
the same time though Paul McCartney
after he was killed and replaced with
another left-handed bassist just kidding
I don't really buy the conspiracy theory
no but McCartney's done some some see
here's the thing a lot of people say
McCartney has done so much more but it's
because he wasn't assassinated and he
was able to remain alive so I think I
think I'm kind of a Lennon guy what
about you Poe I'm a Paul McCartney guy
for her and it's because mostly the
style of music but you know you can
compare the ten years or so of work
after the Beatles broke up
ya know before John Lennon was killed
and I think that Paul McCartney was far
more successful with what he was able to
do with wings than Lennon was I mean at
that point you know arguably so I mean I
think for me it's just like my parents
loved John Lennon and growing up I just
there was a lot of folklore around John
Lennon but I don't know you know I'm
just not a big enough Beatles guy to
even have a super strong opinion on it
you got a little I'm sorry what was that
I'm having a real hard time here that's
not good that's not good you said okay
all right yeah I'm sorry I don't have a
better answer but I'm having a very hard
time here in that collar let's take a
quick break if you're waiting on hold
don't hang up we're taking more calls
after the break